the main finding in this study is that
people who drink large amounts often
binging on the weekends 18:30 drinks
those people have a greater ability to
consume acetic acid or acetate in their
brains than light drinkers are
non-drinkers when you drink alcohol your
liver converts the alcohol pretty
rapidly begins to convert it into
acetate and it produces more acetate
than it can use so that acetate spills
out into the blood once it's in the
blood it circulates through your body
and it can go to your brain the
potential harm of acetate going into the
brain is actually threefold acutely so
in the very short term we know that when
acetate is oxidized in the liver it
promotes inflammation and people who
drink heavily can accumulate fat and on
their liver it makes them insulin
resistant it promotes eventually it can
promote liver failure well if it's
oxidized in the brain in large
quantities it may also be inflammatory
in the brain that's something we still
need to investigate when people go for a
day or two with without eating enough
and then they drink acutely their blood
sugar can drop the brain relies almost
entirely on sugar for its energy needs
and if someone is drinking drinking
alcohol and gets acetate and get energy
from that acetate in their brain I think
they won't be aware of it consciously
but their brain is going to learn that
they can get energy from acetate another
potential harm in this is that when you
oxidize acetate you form adenosine as a
product now adenosine is a chemical that
makes you feel sleepy it's sedating
imagine that they're very heavy drinkers
have twice the ability to consume
acetate as a light drinker so they're
likely to be making more adenosine
inside their brains than the light
drinkers do and the brain is going to
adapt to that
and in someone who's dependent then we
predict that the adenosine is going to
be something they've become accustomed
to and when they stop drinking say if
they decide they're going to stay sober
they withdraw from the alcohol but that
acetate can stay elevated for 24 hours
after they stop drinking and then
they'll start withdrawing from the
acetate and the adenosine and the
implications of these results for
detoxification are that given that an
alcoholic is likely to have adapted to
the presence of an acetate in the brain
and then when they stop drinking the an
acetate goes away and they feel
withdrawal there's there's good an urge
to to begin drinking again to replace
the alcohol and replace the acetate
there's potential that acetate could be
used as a treatment for alcohol
dependence people to help people
nothing's going to make it easy but it
may help people when they go through
withdrawal in addition to the other
measures that we already take I wouldn't
I wouldn't suggest that people go start
drinking vinegar so they can detox that
wouldn't be safe but this is a line of
research we want to investigate and if
it's successful we need to find a way to
deliver it cheaply and practically